What are we?
What do we stand for?
I'm going to Mandalore
so that I may be forgiven
for my transgressions.
Hang on, kid.
This is the way.
The Mandalorian Season three Streaming
March 1st only on Disney Plus.
Welcome back, everyone is Charlie.
They dropped the New Mandalorian Season
three trailer.
There's a bunch of new footage.
We'll break it all down
and talk about Grogu
versus Anakin Skywalker or Darth Vader,
as he would have been during Order 66,
because it definitely
seems like they're hyping up
an encounter between the two of them.
Why else would they continue flashing back
and show you Anakin
Skywalker getting ready to bust in
where Grogu is hiding?
If you're brand new to the channel,
I'll be doing videos for all the episodes,
just like I do for all the other previous
Star Wars series.
Be sure to subscribe to get them.
I'll do a giveaway for Disney
Plus memberships
when we get a little bit closer.
And we have Super Bowl trailers
coming in a couple weeks,
you will probably get another
Mandalorian Season three trailer then.
But a big part of The Mandalorian Season
three in continuing seasons is the dual
meaning the name of the show
The Mandalorian in the dual
meaning of the prophecy about the child
who would bring balance to the force
that we've typically thought
of as Alnwick and Skywalker.
But to make a Game of Thrones George R.R.
Martin reference,
people often misinterpret prophecies.
The reality is usually much
more complicated than that,
because Grogu,
who is basically been acknowledged
by the Star Wars
people as the future of the force.
So starting with the big stuff first Grogu
in Anarchy in Skywalker or Darth Vader,
like I said, as
he would have been at the time
when this scene is happening
in these flashbacks,
it seems like we're getting more
of Grogu's
memories of Order 66 at the Jedi Temple
while it was all going down.
As he continues to unlock
more hidden memories that he had buried
because of all of his trauma.
One of the other reasons
why he's suppressed all of his abilities
and his memories of the Emperor
and the inquisitors.
Darth Vader
would not find him after the fact,
but he was hiding in the outer rim.
That's why during the Mandalorian season
two, when he set the beacon off on Titan,
basically
anybody who had any kind of force
sensitivity would have been able
to detect that around the galaxy.
Good people and bad people like Darth Jedi
or other Sith that might be out there
in other Jedi like Luke Skywalker,
just because Luke Skywalker is the person
who came during the Mandalorian finale
to pick him up does mean that other
Dark Jedi or other villains out there
potentially didn't detect him as well.
But a big part of his time
with Luke Skywalker was learning to unlock
his memories, and it just sounds like he's
continuing to do that.
They kind of implied that when Luke
Skywalker said goodbye to him, like, Oh,
you know. Continue to remember things.
Remember your training?
He set him on the path.
Later in the other trailer scenes,
you see him
continuing to use his abilities
in a more active way.
But it also sounds like it's part of him
remembering things.
He's starting to remember
the circumstances of his escape
from the Jedi Temple, how he survived.
During the book of Boba Fett,
they hinted at
who could potentially have saved him
like This is the Jedi Librarian,
and these other Jedi here
could have led to him escaping.
But the only reason for them
to keep flashing back to Grogu
during order 66 like we've already done
in a couple of different series.
At this point, we've even seen
Anthony and Skywalker in flashbacks
would be to confirm
who actually saved Grogu once and for all.
Like, No, no, it was actually this person.
And here's the big part to show Grogu
who having a face to face
with the Anakin Skywalker
while he was killing all the younglings
in other Jedi
while they were trying to protect them.
Like we've been posting all the memes,
joking
about grogu and Anakins relationship
after order 66 like, haha, I survived,
but it's almost like
they're really paying that off
because in this trailer scene
you see what would be in a can.
Skywalker's lightsaber
cut through this door
in a bunch of other Jedi masters
with their light sabers ready to face him.
And it would have had
to have been Anakin
because he's the only person going around
with a lightsaber killing other Jedi.
Obviously we know how this goes down.
He kills 99% of them
with only a few survivors.
They did another flashback
during the Obi-Wan
Kenobi episode to show you
what happened to Reba.
She was a Padawan who was taken
by the inquisitors to become one of them.
When Order 66 went down.
One of two things happened
at the Jedi Temple around the galaxy.
Just in general,
When Darth Vader and the other inquisitors
would find force sensitives,
they'd either kill you outright in Darth
Vader did this a lot for funny reasons.
I'll explain the second for different
reasons later on when he was older,
or if you were capable of
being turned to the dark side,
they would throw you into training
at the Fortress.
Inquisitor is to become another inquisitor
like Riva.
The Grand Inquisitor, for instance,
used to be one of the Jedi
Temple Guardians on course.
On he's featured in the Clone Wars
episodes during Asuka's trial,
he had grown jaded with the Jedi Order
so that by the time Order 66 had happened,
he officially turned to the dark side when
the Emperor called for order 66 in help.
Anakin Skywalker or in the others
kill the Jedi and capture them
depending on the conditions.
I think the idea in this flashback
scene is we're seeing Anakin
mostly in his seek and destroy mode,
going around the Jedi temple,
killing all the younglings
and the other Jedi.
And it sounds like they want you to think
that their ultimate plan for grogu
you at least,
is Anakin Skywalker
and the Clone Troopers are planning here.
Had they been able to get their hands on
him, would be to turn grogu
you to the dark side and make him one
of the inquisitors, or at least try to.
Jon Favreau and Dave Filoni have talked
a lot about Grogu and his potential.
The other actors have talked
about this as well too.
Like he's meant to be truly ego-less.
Let's just open to any ideas
that are handed to him.
So theoretically, he has infinite
potential to become a powerful good force
user or a very powerful dark side
Sith force user in there trying to show us
how things could have gone another way
had he not been saved.
You could be looking
at like the Sith version of Yoda.
Basically, they would have gained someone
with even more potential
than the Emperor in the force,
someone on Yoda's level.
But is a Sith in a can Skywalker?
Darth Vader would have been
the only known person
so far who would have been more powerful.
Technically,
when you're talking about power levels
in the Force and Anakin Skywalker, it's
more about potential for power
in his stronger connection to the force.
That's why his force users become older.
They become theoretically more powerful
rather than like a normal life.
Where you get older, you get weaker.
The reason why Jedi insist
get more powerful as they get older
is because they grow closer to the force
and because of the circumstances
of Alien Skywalker's birth,
he was just naturally much closer
to the force than almost everyone else.
Yoda's
race is one of the few exceptions of that.
Like every member of Yoda's
race is born extremely close to the force,
with a lot of potential.
But even amongst them,
they all have different power levels
that they're not all born
extremely powerful.
But in this moment here, when this would
have been happening, it sounds like Rogue
wouldn't have been able
to completely withstand and against power.
Even though he and Aniket
are the same age.
If it wasn't clear
they were meant to be about the same age
they were born in the same year,
it was the Grogu
who came to the Jedi Temple before
Anaconda, because the whole idea is that
and again didn't come until he was quote
unquote too old, according to Master
Yoda, too old to begin the training.
But because of the way Yoda's race
develops in ages, Grogu was basically
still a child when Order 66 was happening,
even though he was
just as old as Anakin Skywalker,
he had just as much potential for power.
Is Anakin Skywalker
just because of his biology.
His experiences had not had
as much training as Anakin
Skywalker had, So physically in the moment
he just couldn't match.
And again,
Skywalker did the exact same way.
You also look at the flashbacks,
the Grogu who is having like
just horror in his eyes.
It seems like he's frozen in terror.
So even if he had been able
to fight Anakins Skywalker,
he might have just been frozen in fear,
watching him slice through all of his
friends and fellow trainees and paragons.
What I'm really interested to see, though,
is if there's a big twist
with what happened to grow goo
in how he got saved.
If the person who saved Grogu
who was really wait for it
and can Skywalker himself like we're
all expecting to see Anakin Skywalker
continue slicing his way
around through all the younglings R.I.P.
other Jedi when he gets to grow goo,
the other Jedi sacrifice themselves
and one of them is able to get him away.
We've all been expecting it
to be a really big character
or some other person
that we haven't seen before.
But what if Big Twist
the Jedi were not successful
in sacrificing themselves to save him
and Akin was too powerful, killed them all
and did get to grow, grew.
But instead of handing him
over to the Emperor,
he allowed Grogu to escape on purpose.
One of the big things with any kid
Skywalker or Darth Vader
as he became in the Empire
is that they never trusted each other.
They never liked each other.
It was mostly
a partnership of convenience.
They kind of show you
this during the Obi-Wan Kenobi series.
They get a little bit into it,
but the whole idea is that Darth Vader
doesn't really care that much
about the empire itself.
He just cares about his order
in the galaxy,
his idea of what order represents to him.
The empire, the empire, everyone in it,
like all the officers,
the other inquisitors
are just tools to him to be used.
So he doesn't really care
if they live or die.
One of the big jokes of the character
is that he kills as many Imperials
as other rebels do.
That should be in the briefing
for all new Imperial Academy cadets.
Your chances of dying
at the hands of a rebel are just as good
a dying at the hands of Darth Vader
if you displease him.
And one of the things that Darth Vader
would do when he and the inquisitors
were going around hunting down
the Jedi after Order 66, is that any time
they would find
some really powerful resource,
like a really powerful Jedi
holy Quran or really powerful force user,
he would usually try to kill them
or destroy the artifact
so that the emperor couldn't
use them against him
because the whole idea in the Sith is
there's always two like rule of two.
That means that
if you want to become a Seth,
you either have to kill the previous
apprentice or the previous master.
And Darth Vader really didn't want to die.
So he's busy killing all the other people
that could potentially have replaced him,
which is probably why he wouldn't
want the emperor to get his hands on Grogu
because theoretically, Grogu
who could become just as powerful, if
not more powerful than Anakin Skywalker.
There's also the whole idea
that the prophecy
about the child of the force
has been misinterpreted.
So when all the Jedi,
Yoda, Mace Windu,
everyone else, Obi-Wan
Kenobi, are talking about
the prophecy of the force,
you've heard the prophecy.
Oh, there's a child
that will bring balance to the force.
George
Lucas has talked about this, ironically,
because mistakenly, Mace Windu, Yoda,
the other Jedi thought that that balance
meant getting rid of the dark side,
getting rid of the Sith Force
users out there,
when really it was the opposite of that.
There's this whole idea
that the Jedi order had become jaded
over time and needed
just like a complete reformation.
So things were balanced
but back towards the dark side.
And now the idea that things
are balancing out again and Grogu
who is a big part of that.
So the idea that the prophecy, the force,
the child who would bring balance
is just more complicated.
The grogu who is part of that prophecy as
well as and again, Skywalker like Grogu,
who is part of bringing balance to the
greater idea of the force in the galaxy.
But let me know in the comments.
Who do you think actually saved Grogu
Do you think it actually was?
And again, Skywalker, who was trying
to keep him away from the emperor,
not so much because he cared about Grogu,
but because he didn't want the emperor to
train an even more powerful replacement.
Ultimately.
But like I said,
we'll probably get a couple more trailers
before episode one starts
it starting at the beginning of March,
just like they say in the trailers.
We don't wait that long
before we get here.
There'll be a ton of trailers between now
and the Super Bowl,
so I'll try to do videos
for as many things as possible.
But if you have any requests
or big questions,
just write them in the comments below.
James Gunn just made this huge
announcement, dropped this big trailer
for like the DC Phase
one of his new rebooted movies.
They're calling it DC Chapter one.
Click here to watch that and click here
for my other Mandalorian Season
three trailer video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.